الشركه المصنعه لدبابات لوبردي تعلن
قدرتها على تسليم 139 دبابه اوكرانيا اذا
لزم الامر
مراسلون بلا حدود تؤكد اعتقال 55 صحفيا
ايرانيه منذ اندلاع الاحتجاجات ضد النظام
هيئه الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه تبحث
مقترحا باعتماد اللقاح كرونه بشكل سنوي
لمواجهه المتحولات
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مشاهدينا اوقاتكم بكل الخير
اهلا بكم الى فتره اخباريه جديده من
العربيه نبداها بهذه النشره على متحدث
باسم شركه الدفاعيه الالمانيه ان الشركه
قد تسلم 139 دبابه الى اوكرانيا اذا لزم
الامر اضافه ان شركه يمكننا تسليم 29
دبابه منها بحلول ابريل الى مايو
وبامكانها ايضا انتاج 22 دبابه في نهايه
عام 20 23 او اوائل عام 20 24 مشيرا الى
قدره الشركه على تسليم اوكرانيا 48 دبابه
لو بارت 1 الاقدم لكن من دون اعطاء اطار
زمنيا محتمل
الحرب في اوكرانيا مستعره تواجهها حرب
اخرى بين قاده اوروبا في خضم معركه ايراده
الجدل والاتهامات المواجهه لبرلين
بالتقاعس عن دعم كيف على منسوبها بين
الحلفاء الغربيين المانيا في الاتهامات
تاره وتقول انها ليست حجره عثره في طريق
تزويد اوكرانيا بالعتاد
لكن اذا طلب منا فلن نقف في الطريق
الدبابات المطلوبه ليس للتجول في الشارع
ليدافع الاوكرانيون عن انفسهم افهموا مدى
اهميته هذه الدبابات وندرك ذلك تماما لهذا
السبب نحن مع جميع شركائنا في عمليه
المشاورات
وتاره اخرى تدعو الى التحلي بالصبر بشان
قرار ارسال دبابات اليو بارك الى الجيش
الاوكراني فمصلحه برلين تتمثل في اتخاذ
القرار بعنايه لانه قد يؤثر عليها يقول
وزير الدفاع الالماني
تردد برلين دفع بولندا الى الاعلان عن
تشكيل تحالف يضم البلدان التي تملك دبابات
اليو بارك والمستعده لتقديمها الى كاف
منتقده المانيا على اضاعه الوقت
الى اوكرانيا وحتى لو لم نحصل على هذه
الموافقه سنستمر في تسليم دباباتنا مع
الاخرين الى اوكرانيا
والتطورات تاتي في وقت تعمل فيه المانيا
على حساب كل المعادلات وعدم التورث في حرب
مباشره مع روسيا الغاضبه تقارير ذكرت
النبرلين لن ترسل دبابات الى اوكرانيا الا
اذا فعلت واشنطن الامر نفسه
بلال البوجدين العربيه
الدبابات الثقيله راس الحربه في اي هجوم
او دفاع توفر مستوى عاليا جدا من الحمايه
ضد اسلحه النيران المباشره
تساعد في التحرك بسرعه على الطرق
والتضاريس الوعره تعمل على الاتجاهات
الحاسمه وخرق المناطق المحصنه والنفاذي
عمق العدو
تعد القوه الضاربه الاهم في القوه
العسكريه لاي الجيش
تنفذ عمليات الالتفاف والتطبيق وشقر
دفاعات العدو وتدميرها
تمتلك قوه اختراق اكبر
وتوفر القوه الناريه والقدره على المناوره
للمساعدات
49 مليار منذ بدايه
عقب اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبيه
جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 500 مليون يورو
واضاف من جهه ثانيه ان روسيا لم ترسل اي
اشاره رغبتها في السلام
اعلن رئيس الاوكرانيه
الاوكرانيين لن يتمكنوا من مغادره
اوكرانيا الا للحراره العمل فقط خلال فتره
الاحكام العرفيه وامرز المسك مجلس الوزراء
باجراء تغيرات على قواعد عبور حدود الدوله
في حدود خمسه ايام الرئيس الاوكرانيه قال
ان المعركه من اجل دمباز والجنوب مستمره
وان قوته سترد وبقوه على اضربه الروسيه
وتناقلت وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه نبا
اقاله قائد الادارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
في سومي وخرسون وزباروجيا
اكد مسؤول عن كريم كبير في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه البنتاجون ان خطوط المواجهه في
اوكرانيا لا تتحرك كثيرا باستثناء مدينه
محمود واضاف المسؤول الامريكي ان
المساعدات الاخيره من قبل الولايات
المتحده والدول الاخرى خلال الايام
الماضيه هي الاكبر مشيرا الى ان
الاوكرانيين يتسلموا دبابات من دول صديقه
من صناعه الروسيه كذلك اكد المسؤول
الامريكي ان روسيا ادخلت عشرات الالاف من
الجنود الى ساحه المعركه خلال الاسابيع
الاخيره ووصف هؤلاء الجنود بانهم غير
مدربين بشكل كافر ولا يحملون اسلحه مناسبه
كذلك اكد المسؤول الامريكي ان روسيا لا
تزال تريد شراء واستعمال المسيارات
الايرانيه في المعركه
خوفا من استهدافه بضربه المباشره من
اوكرانيا رئيس بوتين ينصب نظام الدفاع جوي
من طراز باتسير اس 1 بالقرب من مقر اقامته
وفق تقرير نشراته احدى وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه المستقله وقال موقع ايجينتس تي في
او الروسيه المستقل ان منظومه بانسير كما
وضعها بالقرب من منزل بوتين في منطقه
نوفوجورود والاسبوع الماضي بدات تداول
مقاطع الفيديو على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي التي اظهرت صورا لانظمه
موضوع على اسطح العديد من المباني
الحكوميه الرئيسيه في موسكو صحيفه ديليمال
البريطانيه قالت انه تم نشر نظام الدفاع
بانسر ايضا
بالقرب من قصر فاديل الرئاسي في شرفو وهي
قريه بين موسكو وسام بطرس كذ ده تم نشر
انظمه مماثله في مقر اقامه الرئيس الرسمي
في نوفو اوغاريو لوفو ياتي ذلك بعده
هجومين يشتبه انهما بطائرات مسيره
اوكرانيه على قاعدتين جويتين في عنق روسيا
في ديسمبر الماضي وتم تصميمه نظام الحمايه
بانثر للمنشات الحكوميه والصناعيه من
الطائرات والمروحيات والذخائر الدقيقه
وصواريخ كروز وطائرات العسكريه بدون طيار
تلعب الخنادق دورا محوريه لدى القوات
الاوكرانيه في الجبهات الاماميه للقتال
حيث شيد الجنود الاوكران مجموعه من تلك
الخنادق بالمقابل حفره القوات الروسيه
الخنادق وعزاز الدفاعاتها في المناطق
الواقعه تحت سيطرتها
فقط
بالاضافه الى خنادق اخرى تم تشيدها على
طول حدود اوكرانيا مع بلاروسيا لتشكل
جميعها خط الدفاع الاول للجنود
الاوكرانيين في مواجهه روسيا يعيش
المجندون الشتاء في الخنادق مثل جميع
الجنود منذ قرون النظم تشكل تلك المواقع
مصدات الدفاعيه مصممه للوقوف في وجه اي
هجوم كما تعطل الخنادق والتحصينات اي توغل
محتمل في تلك المنطقه لكن الارضيه الصلبه
التي يفضلها بنات هذه الخنادق قد تجعل من
السهل على العدو التقدم وقد يشكل موقعهم
احيانا هدفا سهلا ان تم استهدافه من على
القمم العاليه تستقبل كالخنادق جنود العدو
مسلحين بالقنابل اليدويه والبنادق الرشاشه
ويحاولون الاقتراب قدر المستطاع لمجرد
القاء القنابل اليدويه على الخنادق في
معظم الاحيان يموت الجنود في كتل من الطين
الملوثه على حدود هذه الخنادق
بين الحياه والموت تقف ارواح الجنود بين
الجدارين تحت الارض بين الصقيع ونيران
المدافع متسلحين بخنادقهم في المنطقه
المحرمه
الخناقه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
ذكرت منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود ان السلطات
الايرانيه اعتقل 3 صحفيات على خلفيه انشطه
متعلقه بالتغطيه الاعلاميه منذ بدايه
الاحتجاجات في منتصف سبتمبر الماضي قالت
المنظمه في بيان ان عدد الصحفيين الذين
القت سلطه الايرانيه القبض عليهم منذ
بدايه الاحتجاجات على وفاه مساء ميني
ارتفع الى 55 من بينهم 16 صحفيه واضاف
البيان ان السلطات لا تزالوا تحتجز 27 من
الصحفيين بينما اخذت سبيل الاخرين بكفاله
في انتظار محاكمتهم بعد المنظمه ايضا
السلطات الايرانيه الى الافراج الفوريه عن
الصحفيين المعتقلين واسقاط جميع التهم
المواجهه اليهم
اعلن جريت جنزير محامي اسره السجين
الايراني الامريكي سماك نام مازي المسجون
حاليا في سجن ايفين بطهران ان موكله انهى
اضرابه عن الطعام بعد اسبوع من دخوله في
الاضراب واعلن انه يعاني من انخفاض الضغط
وفقدان الوزن وكان نمازي بعث برساله الى
رئيس الولايات المتحده جوبايدن اعلن فيها
اضرابه عن الطعام وانتقد ايضا رؤساء
امريكا السابقين نماذي قال في رسالته ان
كل ما يريده هو ان يخصص بيضا دقيقه واحده
من وقته لمعاناه الرهائن الامريكيين في
ايران وحكم على سماكه ووالده بقزنا بالسجن
عشر سنوات بتهمه التجسس لصالح واشنطن
لكنهما والحكومه الامريكيه نفيا
اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه فرض عقوبات
جديده على ايران واوضحت بيان ان العقوبه
الجديده تستهدف 10 افراد والمؤسسه
التعاونيه تابعه للحرس الثوري اضاف البيان
ان العقوبات شاملات نائبه وزير المخابرات
الايراني واربعه من قاده الحرس الثوري
واكدت الخزانه الامريكيه ان العقوبات
استهدفت مسؤولين عن القمع في ايران
والجهات التي تمولهم
اعتبرت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انيلينا
بربوكا ان العقوبات ليست كافيه لمواجهه
ايران مجددا على ضروره ادراج الحرس الثوري
على قوائم الارهاب لكنها هذه الخطوه اثارت
جدلا من حيث الالي القانونيه لتنفيذها حيث
يتطلب تصنيف الحركه الثوريه منظمه
الارهابيه قرارا قضائيا اوروبيا هذا ما
اكد عليه مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبيه جوزيل مؤكدا ان التكاثر
لا يمكنه ادراج الحرس الثوري الايرانيه
على قائمه البيانات الارهابيه الا بعد
صدور قرار من محكمه في الاتحاد تفيد بذلك
هذا ويتطلب الامر حسب بريل اذانه قانونيه
ملموسه
نتيجه
هناك العديد من وجهه النظر حول ذلك لكن لا
يمكن ادراج الحرس الثوري الايرانيه على
قوائم الارهاب دون قرار قضائي قرار
المحكمه اولا فلا يمكن تصنيف اي شخص بسبب
كرهي له لذلك يجب اصدار القرار عندما تقر
دوله اوروبيه حكما رسميا بناء على اسس
قويه حينها يمكن العمل على المستوى
الاوروبي
من الحصول على سلاح النووي يجب ان يكون
هدفا مشتركا لاسرائيل والولايات المتحده
معا مشيرا الى ان الخطر الذي تشكله ايران
على العالم والمنطقه يتمثل باستمرار تهران
في تطوير السلاح النووي
اعلنت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه عن بدء
تدريب المشترك مع الجيش الاسرائيلي في شرق
البحر المتوسط وقالت قياده في بيان ان
التدريبات دخول تعزيز استعداد القوات
ويؤكد التزام مباشره تجاهها منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وذكر البيان ان التدريب يشارك فيه
اكثر من 140 طائره من بينها قادفات ب 52
لاستراتيجيه وطائرات f55
و12 قطعه بحريه ورجمات صواريخ وغيرها
ونبقى معكم في سياق هذه النشره ولدينا
البيت الابيض يؤكد ان تفتيش منزل رئيس
بطلب من محامي
[موسيقى]
البعض يقول بان الناس
تهوى اليوم البعد عن واقعها وحياتها
والاتجاه نحو الخيال والاحلام
كانكم انتم تعيشون في ابراج مختلفه
الناس توجيه الاخرين كماله يا اخي نشوف
بعض الكلمات لها دور ولها اثر يعني كلمه
تعملوا فيك يا اخي لو اجتمع المصلحون على
انسان لا يريد ان يتحرك او يتغير والله لن
يتغير المرحله الملكيه يا صديقي ليس
الدعوه الى القعود والعزال عن الحياه في
علم الاخلاق يقول دائما الفضيله بين
فضيلهتين متى يمكن يوصل للانسان المرحله
الملكيه المساله لها علاقه بعمره لا اثبت
الكمال لكن في البعض احيانا نفسه قصير
سؤال مباشر مع خالد مدخلي الجمعه الخامسه
والنصف على شاشه العربيه
لنبدا بموضوع اللاجئين والنازحين هناك
مئات انسانيه
معظم هؤلاء اللاجئين هم من النساء
والاطفال
فنحن نتحدث الان يتشدد القصف والذي دار
فيه قتال عنيف
الروسيه لتشمل العديد من المدن اسمح لي ان
ابدا بهذه العواجل القوات الروسيه على بعد
30 كلم من وسط المدينه
كبيره على روسيا العقوبات ستكون تصاعديا
ماذا يعني هذا نستمر
التي رايناها قبل قليل
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد ساعات على هجومي لوس
انجلوس الذي اودع بحياتي 11 شخصا وجرح
عشره اخرين قتل سبعه اشخاص في اطلاق النار
في موقعين شمال كاليفورنيا حسبما ذكرت
شبكه سي ان بي اس نيوز
وقع في ساحل هضم مومباي على بعد حوالي 50
كم جنوب سان فرانسيسكو وتم القاء القبض
على الجاني في ما لم تعرب بعد دوافع
الهجوم
قال رئيس الوزراء العراقيه محمد السوداني
ان البلاد كانت تبيع 300 مليون دولار في
اليوم الواحد فيما عجز الاقتصاديون عن
تفسير ما الذي يستورده العراق حيث يبيع
يوميا بهذا الرقم على حد تعبيره وشدد
سوداني على ان حكومته جاده في تطبيق
المعايير الصحيحه التي تضمن المحافظه على
المال العام
له فيها هدر وفيها اموال تخرج بغطاء تجاره
غير مشروعه تهريب غسيل اموال شتتهم
والتحليلات
واغلبها صحيح يعني لا ليس في اطار التهمه
كنا نبيع 300 مليون دولار في اليوم الواحد
وكل الاقتصاديين والمختصين يقفون عاجزين
على تفسير انه ما الذي يستورده العراق
يوميا حتى يبيع 300 مليون دولار
عام
مقدار الضرر بالخزينه العامه
فساد عمليات بيع العمله
ازمه الدولار بالعراق واشنط رصدت عمليه
بيع الغير قانونيه
تطبيق بفواتير مصارف عراقيه كشف الكثير من
الفواتير المزوره
من بيع الدولار كعوبه تقرير هيئه النزاهه
الاتحاديه عام 2022 اكبر عمليه فساد تتم
من خلال مزاد العمره
خزينه
العراقيه
[موسيقى]
تابعه لايران
تبحث هو هيئه الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه
مقترحا بادراج اللقاح المضاده لكرونه
ليكونونه منتظما بشكل سنوي حسب ما افادت
وثائق نشرتها الوكاله الحكوميه الاقتراح
الصدر من علماء تبعين الهيئه اوصوا بان
يتم تحديث اللقاح بشكل دوري ليكون فعالا
ضد سلالات الجديده من الفيروس ويقترح
العلماء ان يكون اللقاح على شكل جرعه
واحده
وجرعتين لكبار السن والذين يعانون من ضعف
جهاز المناعه
هذا واطلقت منظمه الصحه العالميه نداء
للجميع قرابه الثلاثه مليارات دولار هذا
العام للاستجابه لعدد غير مسبوق من حاله
الطوارئ الصحيه
وتضاف الحروب او تضيف الحروب وتداعيتها
المدمره على السكان المدنيين في كل من
اوكرانيا واليمن وسوريا واثيوبيا بالاضافه
الى الكوارث المرتبطه بتغير المناخي
كالفيضانات والجفاف وانعدام الامن الغذائي
التي اضعفت بالطبع شبكات الرعايه الصحيه
بعد ثلاثه اعوام من تفشي كورونا حسب
المنظمه
ذكر البيت الابيض
رئيس ان بعض الوثائق السريه ترجع الى فتره
ولايه بيض في مجلس الشيوخ وانا وثائقه
اخرى كانت من فتره توليه منصب نائب رئيس
في اداره الرئيس الاسباق اوباما من عام
2009 حتى عام 2017 ورفض المتحدث باسم
البيت الابيض
تفاصيل اكثر عن المحتوى الدقيق للمواد
الماخوذه من منزل الرئيس
تسريحات الموظفين في قطاع تكنولوجيا
بالجمله مستمره ولا تزالوا الشركات الكبرى
تعلن عن تسريح الاف العمال بل وخطط لتخفيض
العماله التقرير التالي يكشف اسباب تراجع
الارباح واللجوء الى تقليص المصاريف في
هذه الشركات
الى اي مكان قبل تخفيف حمولته الزائده
ربما يلخص هذا المفهوم ما قامت به شركات
التكنولوجيا العملاقه خلال الاسابيع
الاخيره من موجات التسريح بالالاف طالت
موظفين وحتى المتعاقدين لكن لا يمكن فهمه
هذا الفعل دون دراسه ما حدث في عامين غلب
عليهما كورونا وتاثيره على سلوك الناس
والشركات فجاه وجد قطاع التكنولوجيا نفسه
في بؤره الاهتمام والتركيز مع الاغلاقات
التي عمت العالم وارقت الموظفين والطلاب
في منازلهم
حينها تضاعف الطلب على اجهزه الكمبيوتر
المحمول لتلبيه معايير العمل عن بعد تضاعف
معه حجم التسوق عبر الانترنت مع توقف في
اغلب المحل عن استقبال الزبائن حتى
التسليه اغلقت الملاعب والحدائق ليصبح
الميدان الوحيد المتاح العاب الفيديو
والافلام
لذا حين تضاعف كل هذا كان لابد لعدد
العاملين في هذه الشركات
ايواكب الزياده لكن الان انتهت الاغلاقات
وعدت الامور الى طبيعتها لتفكر الشركات في
التاقلم مع وضعها الجديد فما عوده الحياه
الى طبيعتها وتراجع الارادات كان لابد من
التخلص من الحمل الزائد لكن ازمتين اخرين
ظهرت في الصوره
الاولى هي التضخم واتجاه اغلب الدول لرفع
اسعار الفائده
والثانيه والتي تعد نتيجه للاولى وهي
الركود التي بدات مؤشراته في الظهور
بمختلف الاسواق
50 الف موظفين دفعوا ثمن ما حدث خاصه في
شركات عمالقه التكنولوجيا امازون وجوجل
ومايكروسوفت وميتا لكن الاخطر ان هذه
الارقام حدثت بينما لم يدخل الاقتصاد
العالمي مرحله الركود فقط ترك الباب جاسم
محسن العربيه
استنى في المحقق العدلي في انفجار مرفا
بيروت تحقيقاته بعد ثلاثه عشر شهرا على
تعليقها جرى دعوه ورفعها عدد من المدعي
عليهم ضده وفقا لما افاد به مسؤول القضائي
القاضي طارق بيطار قرر اخلاء سبيل خمسه
موقفين منذ حدوث الانفجار الذي هز العاصمه
في اغسطس 20 20 بينهم مسؤولان سابقان في
المرفق اضافه الى للدعاء على ثمانيه اشخاص
جدد بينهم مسؤولان امنيان رفيعان هم
المدير العام للامن العام عباس ابراهيم
والمدير العام لامن الدوله طوني صليبه حسب
المسؤول القضائي
هذه هي العالميه
خوفا من استهدافه بشكل مفاجئ بوتين ينشر
منظومه الدفاع جويه حول اماكن اقامته في
روسيا
مراسلون بلا حدود تؤكد وتقال 55 صحفيا
ايرانيا منذ ذراعي الاحتجاجات ضد النظام
وهيئه الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه تبحث
مقترحا باعتماد اللقاح كرونه بشكل سنوي
لمواجهه المتحورات
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]